correct order is vegetables first
proteins and fats second and starches
and sugars last here are my quick and
dirty thought research does suggest that
meal component order can have a
significant effect on blood sugar though
admittedly most of the research like
this study has been done on folks with
diabetes the study that's often quoted
which is likely the basis for Jesse's
argument found that doing veggies then
protein and carbs or Protein Plus veg
then carbs resulted in lower glucose
levels than having carbs first and I
assume that this is where Jesse got her
magic formula this could mean having a
salad as a starter and then going on to
have your meat and potatoes make sense
but what about a mixed meal like a
sandwich or a burger or even this
beautiful Bountiful salad thankfully we
see a huge benefit on blood sugar since
satiety by simply combining these Foods
Ella my Hunger crush and combo when
parsing them out is inconvenient or
nonsensical this study found for example
that having protein with potatoes or
protein before potatoes both had
significant improvements in blood
glucose and when we look at how similar
these lines are on the graph the
difference to me does not seem like a
big deal certainly not a big enough deal
to have your croutons all by themselves
or to eat the lettuce off your burger
and then have the bun last